y décadas de hostilidad de repente a
punto de terminar en las calles de
jartúm los ciudadanos sudaneses
expresaron sentimientos mixtos sobre la
normalización de las relaciones con
israel algunos ven la decisión como una
necesidad práctica después de
movimientos similares de vecinos árabes
como baréin y emiratos árabes unidos- la
normalización se ha convertido en una
realidad inevitable es el interés de
nuestro país porque muchos países árabes
han normalizado sus relaciones e israel
se ha hecho presente en nuestra vida
pública y en la vida de todos los países
árabes
otros son aún más optimistas sobre el
regreso de sudán a la escena mundial
después de años de conflicto y
aislamiento bajo el mandato de omar
al-bashir apoyó la normalización de los
lazos con israel porque allana el camino
para las relaciones internacionales
especialmente con eeuu se espera que el
acuerdo negociado por eeuu para abrir la
cooperación económica y comercial con
israel se centre primero en la
agricultura
sudán busca que el acuerdo ayude a
aliviar una crisis económica cada vez
más profunda
tanto si normalizamos las relaciones con
israel como
israel debe beneficiar a sudán de alguna
manera en la agricultura por ejemplo
porque sé que israel es uno de los más
fuertes del mundo en el ámbito
tecnológico pero muchos en jartún siguen
oponiéndose a la idea y continúan
considerando a israel como un enemigo
del mundo árabe cualquier país que
normalice las relaciones con israel no
encontrará más convicción y deshonra es
probable que una completa implementación
de las relaciones lleve a algún tiempo
ya que sudan todavía está en proceso de
formar un gobierno civil después de la
caída de omar al-bashir el año pasado